c'est toujours leur de babar issa avec
bravo loto le jeu 100% gratuit qui peut
changer ta vie
téléchargez l'appli jeter gris et tente
de remporter jusqu'à un million d'euros
sans rien faire bravo l'auto facile
d'être riche
[Musique]
bon alors ça c'est un sac à dos alors ça
ça c'est un sac à dos et cheveux ça
c'est une chemise de chirurgiens banon
s'est tenu comme ray encore à l'essai un
pool pouvait on est toujours présent du
sac à dos barre était alors c'est la
maison des sept nains parce que blanche
neige est rentré dedans il ya un café
pipe innovant puisqu'il est un continent
aux coquillages crustacés une pinotte
une méduse un arbre et et c'est une
passe de pipi je le vois bien dans une
maison parce qu a pas de toilettes elles
sont bouchées
mes toilettes sont bouchées je sais ce
que ça fait arrêtez un peu un k way
d'arracher pour ce temps parachute
ouais c'est une combinaison à des
bonbonnes de trucs pour respirer sous un
gilet sauvetage un gilet de sauvetage
[Musique]
gilet de sauvetage nous tu as ton mac
à quel moment tu pantin gilles sauvetage
pour les vacances le mec qui n'aura sera
permanente quoi âgé de sauvetage
[Musique]